(audience clapping)
Hi Farideh.
Hi, Drew, how are you?
I'm ready to get into this.
Tell me everything.
Cool, so this is my take on everyone's fast food favorite,
you know, crunch wrap supreme.
(audience clapping)
I mean, does everybody know what a crunch wrap supreme is?
I think you do, but maybe for those who don't know,
what is it?
What is it, Farideh?
I mean, it's basically all of your favorite things
that might go into like a taco or burrito
wrapped up in a nice little tortilla
with a tostada in between, making it super crunchy,
delicious, kind of fresh, you know, why not?
Okay, so you're gonna keep cooking
and then I'm gonna keep checking in and we're gonna make
this at some point in the show.
Let's do it.
But you'll be here.
I'll be here.
Okay, that is so cool.
All right, 'cause it already smells amazing.
Okay, cool.
So this is my take on everyone's fast food favorite,
you know, crunch wrap supreme.
We've got our ground beef kind of all going, it's seasoned.
What we can do is, we've got queso here.
I noticed.
Do you love queso?
On a double boiler.
So a double boiler is basically water underneath,
its, you know, a heatproof bowl.
We're gonna add in some pickled jalapenos.
Hm-hm.
And so this queso, it's so good, it's so easy.
It's got a mixture of Velveeta and Oaxacan cheese,
some milk and those pickled jalapenos.
And Oaxacan cheese it's from the Oaxacan region of Mexico.
If you didn't have that at home, you could totally
get a mozzarella cheese or something like that.
It's fine.
But then yeah, and then in our ground beef,
it's all kinds of different seasonings in there.
We're gonna assemble these though,
'cause I think that we're basically ready to go.
So we've got our ground beef, I mean the whole studio
smells amazing right now if I do say so myself.
We're gonna put a little bit just in the middle of this.
So 'cause essentially what we're gonna do is, we're building
up a bunch of different things onto here.
It's almost like a bunch of taco fixings on this.
It does smell like the best taco night I've ever been to.
And the seasoning for this, everyone always gets
the packets of taco seasoning.
You can make that so easily on your own.
How?
You just use garlic.
I mean, there's all these things right here.
There's a ground cumin, there's ground coriander,
paprika, cayenne, garlic powder and onion powder.
On top of this, we're gonna start with adding
a little bit of our queso right on top of this.
With the pickled jalapeno.
Yeah!
You know, okay.
On top of that, we're gonna do a tostada.
And that's what makes it the crunch wrap, right?
This is what makes it the crunch wrap, yeah.
And then also we're gonna pan fry it and it's gonna get
even crunchier as you pan fry it.
So, right in the middle there.
And then on top of that, we're gonna do some sour cream.
Hm-hm.
Now also I know, I feel like tostadas
are one of those things that are kind of hard
for people to find a lot of places.
But if you don't have tostadas, you could use Doritos.
My parents who don't really cook a lot of my recipes
and don't eat a lot of fast food either,
made this recipe and they used potato chips.
So you can get that crunch in a lot of different ways.
Potato chips.
Fritos?
You could use Fritos, for sure.
We're gonna add a little bit of tomato on top.
Look, I mean, this is kind of like a little salad.
And that sour cream is like a glue, which works well.
Exactly.
We're gonna do some lettuce as well.
You are going for it with all this stuff and I love it.
I'm watching you.
I know I might be going too big.
No, go big or go home, right?
Right.
Yeah, and then just the more cheese, more cheese on top.
Also, I wish that we could see your dog
back here who is just waiting.
Sit.
So patiently.
He's like, he's like,
this is Douglas's inner dialogue right now,
"Something fall, something fall, something fall."
Yeah, exactly.
(audience laughing)
You'll get it, you'll get it.
All right.
We're gonna do one of these little, yeah,
you're ready for it, but one of the little ones, yeah.
Right there.
Okay, this is where it gets tricky.
Okay?
We've got our pans heating,
but before we even do that, let's add
a little bit of oil to our pan.
So we got a nice hot pan over here.
You ready to do the fold?
Yes.
Okay.
This is literally the trickiest part, okay?
You're gonna fold one little piece up.
Okay.
And then you're gonna pleat it.
So you're gonna do a little pinch like that.
Another little pinch like this, and you have to hold
it the whole time with your little fingies right there.
And yes, I did say fingies.
Oh God.
That's correct.
(Drew groaning)
Oh my gosh, this is where it gets a little intense.
So put your hand kinda here, and you need to, we're gonna
flip this like that and gently, very carefully,
'cause you wanna do it seam side down to seal it all in.
So, right in there, I like to give it a little twirl.
Move it around there, look at that.
Okay.
This couldn't be easier.
I'm gonna turn my heat up a teensy bit.
I mean, this is pretty good.
What kind of, I mean are you ever doing taco night
with your kids?
I do do tacos with the girls.
And they like, I got them into rice and beans really young.
Yeah.
And they love guacamole and chips.
That's like.
Ooh.
Yeah, now I.
Okay, it needs to turn no matter what.
Flip her.
Oh, well, here's the good news.
Mine's popping open a little bit too, it's all right.
It's the right pleating, it's the wrong sear.
See, look at Farideh's.
Gosh, darn it.
(laughing)
I burnt the bottom when we were chatting away.
What can you do?
I'm so relieved.
It's still gonna taste good though.
You know what I mean?
Come on.
(audience clapping)
It's fine.
All right, at least I got the pleating right.
I'm gonna cut mine open and we're gonna.
Yeah, I'm also just gonna do that.
Look at this.
That looks good, right?
(audience clapping)
Hell, yeah.
Hold on, here we go, ready?
Wait for it, listen.
(crunching)
Oh yeah.
Ooh, it's really fun to cut through.
(laughing)
'Cause it's like going, going, crunch, going, going.
Okay, look inside.
Ooh!
Beautiful, right?
Look at that, and you know what's inside it.
You did it all yourself.
Cheers.
Cheers, Farideh.
(laughing)
Turn it around.
(chewing)
Yeah, I mean it tastes like.
I haven't had one of these in a long time
and it's so good.
Oh my God, this is so good.
Let me just try one more bite.
It's crunchy, it's cheesy.
Tell me all about it.
(laughing)
What is it like, Farideh?
Yeah, describe it.
(upbeat music)